pasqua d'une feinte du décor tout comme
son bras droit dans le sang en libye
jeunes et celle qu'on pense que tu es
mon père reviendrons bien d'accord
reviendrai pas on revient doigt par le
reste je sais que je veux rien dire ça
après le plateau les piquets tu veux
faire quoi c'est contre le crois pas je
devais faire essayer ce que tu veux ok
ils vont vous trouvez et chante we have
to cool car tout cela christophe trêve
dans le btp au bar branché et romain ok
ok mon avis c'est trop tard possible de
faire ton truc mais on va le faire
ok aucun gant l'essayer seuil en
essayant au parti vas-y vas-y tu veux
les sens pour guider son passé
sedraoui censure là dedans on est juste
un peu rapidement c'est pour ça les
locaux mais bien l'essayer à les
problèmes auxquels est très bas sont les
chevaux et la droite que sap en guinée
tu parle à tous un droit non mais
quelqu'un même peut pas papa tous
passent par le roi swazi joli ça
à droite de la ferme joli joli paysage
avec de la rivière un pote à la baraque
derrière s'ouvrir un petit peu moins 47
ans barbe soutenu au coeur dans la
montagne mais oui je prépare alors
l'europe
bon swing propose c'est qu'on a mangé
façon le soleil descendre un peu plus
bas il est comme ça toute la nuit au
ballon ça que je lui aurais
c'est joli ça je paysage a laissé des
baisers
de la neige par le barème des quotes
parts et je vais mettre la terre 4h30 du
matin on va se coucher avant de ravir à
travailler comme l'aurait pas fait
et pour lui